l'industrie de la construction rla plein
régime en ce moment au pays le nombre
annualisé de mises en chantier a bondi
de 23% de décembre à janvier pour
dépasser en rythme annualisé 282000
unités les mises en chantier de maisons
unifamiliales à montréal ont atteint
leur plus haut niveau depuis février
dans un autre rapport la schl constate
que l'étalement urbain se poursuit dans
les grandes villes en particulier à
montréal où les nouvelles constructions
sont de plus en plus loin du centre
ville avec nous ce soir comment parler
francis cortellino économiste à la
société canadienne d'hypothèques et de
logement bonsoir bonsoir
alors on parle d'un niveau élevé là à
montréal depuis 2008 on parle de on
parle de combien de maisons exactement
mises en chantier pour le grand montréal
donc le chiffre qui est émis aujourd'hui
par le club du rythme d'activité de
maisons individuelles qui était très
élevé il faut savoir depuis plusieurs
années maintenant on construit beaucoup
moins de maisons individuelles dans le
grand beaucoup d'appartements locatifs
ou des condos donc si on regarde le
rythme était très élevé mais à terme
sont réels de maison forte construite
dans le grand montréal en janvier
c'est seulement 230 par contre 239 se
démarque par rapport aux dernières
années honteuse dans le 115 90 unités il
faut remonter à 2008 environ pouvoir
avoir un niveau d'activité de
construction de maison qui est aussi
élevé par contre ce serait très étonnant
faudra qu'une fois qu'on garde les
niveaux de 2008 par exemple la
construction de 7000 8000 maisons par
année alors que dans les magasins on
n'est plus dans le 2000 2500 mises en
chantier alors je le dis le volume de
janvier voulait attribuer à quoi est-ce
que la pandémie a quelque chose à voir
dans ça mais on voit depuis quelques
mois à montréal et dans d'autres centres
urbains du pays une pression ouvert la
demande de maisons des tâches et des
maisons individuelles autant un marché
du neuf la constante sur le marché de la
revente
on prend un désir d'avoir des espaces
accueillent le plus grand sakho hp rock
par en sorte que la demande s'oriente
plus vers la maison ou de l'argument se
dit et vous noté dans le rapport ayant
rapport de la schl aujourd'hui sur
l'étalement urbain
les nouvelles maisons sont de plus en
plus loin du
centre-ville 1 on est de plus en plus en
banlieue mais on s'éloigne de plus en
plus en terme de banlieue on n'est pas à
5 10 ou 15 km mais même à plus de 30
kilomètres du centre-ville où exactement
alors qu'on après une analyse sur 30 ans
de la construction de maisons et dans
l'ensemble les premières couronnes on
faisait beaucoup de maisons mais
maintenant vous savez et rareté des
terrains un peu partout dans le grand
montréal donc on construit des maisons
de plus en plus loin aux extrémités donc
les villes on en fait un peu plus par an
vous avez une mirabel saint jérôme saint
jean sur richelieu saint colomban donc
aux extrémités du grand montréal où la
course qui sont mortes quand même faible
comparé aux dernières années mais quand
même est concentré dans certaines
municipalités un peu plus ses loyers et
donc on constate cet enjeu de
l'étalement urbain grandir à montréal
plus qu'ailleurs au canada où est donc
enfin l'étude démontré que par exemple
son patron on trouve à cuba on va voir
que quand même beaucoup de constructions
dans le noyau plus actif dans le centre
de la ville les grands tôt près aux deux
congo par exemple alors que le sens de
montréal c'est un peu moins développées
de façon si active alors on n'est plus
visé un peu plus on est tellement donc
des constructions très éloigné du sang
tous les terrains sont abordables peu
cher est-ce qu en sorte que c'est un peu
réglé prennent d'abord des idées pour
certains ménages qui veulent acquérir
une maison mais quatre fois plus
d'aménagements du territoire
environnement et audrey et on construit
moins dans l'est dans les zones où il ya
davantage de ménages à faible revenu
est-ce que ce qui est un enjeu pour
l'abordabilité ici pour les ménages à
plus faible revenu
oui si on revient aux simples avec le
fait que dans des sacs au centre
montréal soit il peut avoir des ménages
avec des revenus plus faibles
ainsi comme on dit que le la concernant
le noyau de montréal est un peu moins
active
par contre on sait depuis quelques
années que c'est vraiment des défis
d'abordabilité par exemple à montréal
dans d'autres centres on a remarqué que
les jeunes ménages aujourd'hui sont plus
de quatre heures que les ménages
autrefois à l'époque des ménages les
plus jeunes de mer qu'on prétend plus
rapidement que les jeunes qui avait
précédé cette tendance aussi brise au
cours de dernières années et on peut
penser avec la hausse des prix très
simple
promu à montréal en 2020 aussi dans les
années qui ont précédé l'accession à la
propriété de mieux beaucoup plus
difficile pour un jeune ménage
montréalais contre x la hausse des prix
d'ailleurs elle se poursuit en ce moment
est-ce qu'elle va se poursuivre tout au
cours de l'année est ce que est ce que
ça va ralentir la hausse des prix à
laquelle on a assisté au cours des
derniers mois mais son verre déjà le
début d'année la hausse des prix de ce
métis coup savoir pour la grande région
de montréal
c'est quand elle est très active oui
d'un côté mais de l'autre côté c'est que
l'offre est très très limité sur le
marché très peu de maisons très peu de
copropriété à vendre c'est qu'il a
énormément de pression sur le marché et
donc en traîne comme vous savez beaucoup
d'histoires de surenchère d'offres
multiples sur les propriétés l'offre est
tellement basse donc ça pousse les
prisons à la hausse en ce moment étant
que l'offre n'augmenteront peut que
penser que les hausses de prix bonbons
ce matin est ce qu on a un marché qui
devient surévalué en ce moment selon
notre dernière notre dernière étude où
on fait un bilan de santé du marché de
l'habitation montréalais jean les
principaux critères autrement qu'on
sauve et autres la surévaluation qui est
à surveiller et à la hausse des prix
celle qu'on appelle la surchauffe bon
que tellement de demandes par rapport à
l'offre de troupes pression sur la
marché et ça après 2 mai face on est
fait de l'accélération des prix dont des
prix qui augmentent de plus en plus
rapidement ce qui peut entraîner des
excités spéculatives par exemple des
gens qui achèteraient dans le but de
revendre avec profit à court terme étant
donné qu'ils sont alors que le mode
les prix ne peuvent qu'augmenter en
plusieurs des autres acteurs
intéressants et importants sauvé pour
marché montréalais canali le contexte
qui est surchauffée pouvoir dernier
point les taux d'intérêt sont bas vont
rester bas probablement encore un
certain temps est-ce que ça alimente est
ce que c'est le principal facteur qui
alimentent le marché en ce moment les
bas taux d'intérêt
les bas taux d'intérêt sont certainement
pas encore très important dans la
demande d'habitations
par contre je dois aussi la nationale
sont qu'on a connu avec la pandémie
un marché de l'emploi qui était très
différent entre les différents groupes
d'âge note franck capillery travers
certains travailleurs qui ont été plus
impacté par la situation
on résume beaucoup leurs dépenses de
déplacement de voyages supérieurs
départ a augmenté et on peut avoir une
caisse d'économie pour acheter des
propriétés alors que les cas perry
travailleurs souvent ça colle des
services soit d un peu moins bien
rémunérés ont effectué mardi dans la
catégorie témoins dans l'achat de
propriétés pour l'immédiat hockey et
donc les gens qui avaient la capacité
ont pu acheter donc sociale entraîné une
hausse des ventes dans les derniers mois
merci de cette analyse francis
cortellino merci à vous pour voir